[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les petits bonsoir mais minet au
patro j'ai une idée qu'est ce que je
peux donner un coup de téléphone mais je
t'en prie nenê allô allô oui c'est moi
qui voulez-vous voir ce soir votre
nounours ou la mère michelle et moi
alors on voit tout le bon et bien je
vous l'envoie relais mon échelle maire
michel aulas mais vite ça chapeau
tu seras père lustucru
[Musique]
le repas de midi apparaîtra le long
terme et chats qui lui a dit je n'ai pas
perdu vous l'avez nous ont trouvés sur
l'air d'être entérinée à être un long et
michel seymour dubonchoix vous aurez
[Musique]
l'air du 3d hologram du complot du chat
la mère michel mine où il nous et nous
oui nous nous sommes croisés
elle était très contente elle m'a dit
qu'elle reviendrait roux pense oui à vue
[Musique]
michel halpérin
j'ai tant de bonne nuit les petits à new
york venus la mère michel eu des enfants
allons envoûte la mère michel au pardon
en route ne nours en rotin ou porto en
route pas trop bonne nuit les petits
faites de beaux
oh
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]